Right when I was a kid in grade school,
I would write really bizarre.
I was always interested in,
in,
um,
murder mysteries and murder and law and,
and sort of the darker impulses of
people.
Um,
so I would write stories about um,
murderous matrons and,
and,
um,
you know,
serial killers who,
were re grandmothers and,
and,
um,
would send these stories off to ellery
queen and,
and,
um,
Alfred Hitchcock and,
you know,
kept getting rejections.
Of course I was like 15 and 14,
so I,
I really didn't expect anything,
but I kept doing it just for fun.
Um,
and then I sort of gave it up and I
figured,
you know,
nobody can really grow up and become a
writer.
I didn't think that was something people
did for a living.
It was sort of a fancy bowl thing.
Um,
and I had planned that go to law school.
that's mostly because I thought that
would be the easiest thing to do.
And I,
I like to argue with people and I like
politics and um,
but while I was in,
in college,
I got an internship at a Philadelphia
magazine and,
and,
um,
one of the things I had to do besides
picking up people's laundry and opera
tickets was a,
in transcribing the interviews,
it was way before anybody had machines
that did that for you.
So,
um,
there are a couple journalists who
would,
who would make me transcribe the
interviews and they would say things
like,
you know,
note how I ask this question.
No,
the way I sort of used in and this word
and the way they answered this,
mark that down.
And it was a very calculated system of
questioning that,
that intrigued me.
And,
uh,
that's when I started wanting to be in
general.